you gotta do the sandwich technique you
gotta go compliment neg compliment and
then it's I think you go up and you're
like hi I like bigger girls
but if
it's kind of your jam and you're being
honest yeah
don't say it and don't say it
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we are talking
indeed about who in this room has the
most RIS oh Riz rizz Factor are we going
on a scale from one to ten or is that
unrizzly like a to z like Anthony to Z
it's like one you're like you know it is
at all and ten you're the rizzler the
rizzler can I can I start with uh 10
I think Anthony Lee is like a 9.5 dude
yeah
on a scale of 100 yeah no no dude you're
very I think you're you're reaching the
rizzler status and I think Ryan is
probably like not far behind you know
I'm too short to be the reason can we
just comment on the the the Riz fit
right here I'm pretty that is pretty
very so I might say this is insecurity
yeah but I disagree with that all right
yeah I disagree that's like over
security Colleen you think you got the
ribs bro no I think I mean like look
look at Steve no no stop don't deflect
dude
it's you or Steve I did bring it up I am
fishing for compromise
I just set it up for yourself can you
imagine I mean either one of you can
sell me mushrooms so that's true I think
me though no no Steve's got the hard
stuff I the way I'm dressed today I got
the light stuff I got this little
sideburns baby yeah he's the candidate I
got the edible shiitake stuff it's not
that Rizzy yeah you're like more of a
farmer yeah but you're not dressed like
it nah but that's what contrasts the
farm life so then it's like Rizzy that's
true it's very rich did you guys know
what rizz was until like a Week Ago by
the way because I still don't really
know
at the gym there's this kid who's seven
he's 16 and he's always uh talking all
this slang the new slang so he keeps us
young and he keeps us on he's like bet
yeah he calls it facts he drives a
ranger over his dad his dad's car right
and he calls it the RIS Rover and I go
oh pretty good did you punch him in the
face every day we punch him so RIS means
range apparently so rizz is like that
cringe word swag
yeah it's like a word for when
um like you can turn the tide in your
favor so where someone wouldn't be
default attracted to you you can do
something to change that I think that's
a cool word so like you could be like
ugly but you could have rizz yeah
exactly
so you could be rizz list and then
develop Riz with work Yeah Yeah by
ringing the game
well we know we know some people who
could probably use a little bit of
wrists
first and last name go ahead uh I don't
remember the name but there's there's a
couple people who are like hey I really
need to like learn how to date people
and Walter
is that his name yeah Walter Walter
there you go yeah Walter
that's not offensive that I said his
name right
and we talked about it here right you
guys are looking at me like I mean who's
gonna turn down more risks he's
developing the rich he's literally going
on his risk page out in Korea he does
say that quite a bit right he's always
talking about how he wants to get with
somebody yeah he specifically is like
going so what's some advice that you
would give somebody I would say don't
talk about it like I do I don't really
yeah
don't ever give advice on rizz either
you have it or you don't is that what
you is that what you mean is that I
think no you gotta watch pickup Artistry
don't talk about how to just watch if
you had a zero RIS right you watch the
pickup Artistry you can get at least a
10. would you say but you have to have a
big hat
your hat would you say it as peacocking
it's a piece of flair I don't know if
the Hat's the peacock on it I know you
need a fuzzy Jamiroquai one if you're
gonna enter that conversation Big Frame
glasses I would call my hat sarcasm and
I would call my outfit sarcasm yeah if I
could call them anything but do you do
you feel like you give off unintended
rizz from your outfit I mean chicks boys
are like hey I want to [__] you real bad
so I'm like I'm married man so that's
the opposite yeah they're just soaking
yeah yeah this is tequil it by Slade
dictionary Riz r-i-z-z all right it's
Charisma is a slang term for skill in
Charming or seducing a potential
romantic partner especially through
verbal communication it is most commonly
applied in the context of men pursuing
women but not always
sex appeal
appeal yeah basically I think that Joe
has an understated amount of risk
because I've seen you well especially
when we were hooking up with chicks back
in the Disney look at that smile dude
look at that smile Joe has a very casual
and like cool yeah there's no
desperation there will never be
desperation yeah he's just very like I
don't know take me or leave me like
we'll see what happens Joe's like we
should hang out and maybe you could come
sit on my face sometime or something
like that yeah and he's not even excited
about it he's like yeah is that a Joe
line
might be like do you like cream pies
no one talks to me so straight up you
must be just an honest person how
refreshing
that's literally like what it is I think
guys are trying so hard to be like oh
yeah oh we're gonna get married and then
it's like she's like
you're lying for stop let's stop [__]
trying that's not right you're just a
genuinely likable Guy rizz is when
you're a scumbag and you're like putting
on them
it's an intent it rizz is all intent I
thought it rizz is like you just like
are mad you just have all this [__]
energy and the chicks just want to [__]
up Maybe not maybe not scumbag but like
it doesn't count as rizz unless you're
calling it it's like a side pocket shot
it's like you got to be like all right
check this out and then you have to do
the thing but if you're just a cool guy
that's just good for you if you're just
a cool guy you might still have some I
don't have rizz then that's just being
genuine that's actually cool like you I
wouldn't call it rizz but he was just
that Coachella that's kind of that's a
Risley Bear right there
traveling and all you had was rizz
because they don't give a [__] about who
you are or what you do it's like all you
can do is like put your best don't
reminisce like that dude shot forward
it's like that especially when you
travel overseas and you're like hola
the way you look at me makes me inspired
I feel like real rizz is capturing or is
it captivating someone that has does not
want to even pay attention to at all I
didn't know that it was Guy specific and
it was it was with dating it's I think
it's just a new slang term for game I
think we don't know what it is I heard
hey look I'm pretty sure I just read the
definition from the 16 year old kid that
I know he says it's short for Charisma
oh okay that kind of makes sense now we
say isma for that
but Chris was not intentional though
right prison is like exactly rizz is
like manufactured Charisma I think some
people can't manufacture Charisma it's
like he got game like I'm saying I'm
guessing if somebody's spitting game
like literally spinning game on somebody
but Apple's risen out has a guy used a
line on you and it worked what kind of
rizz has the guy use the line on you
Anthony did it to me
I'm the authority here
um no we're asking you Colleen no I I
kind of wanted to hear your answer no no
one's ever no one's ever no one's ever
shot a shot at me except Jocko Jacko
will Nick at my dreams
honestly he could have had more race
dude I could have talked me into it in
my dream but he was too he was too
heavy-handed the funny the funny thing
is some guys are so dumb that they
really think like so many women already
like you before you've even said
something and then you just credit your
own verbal communication to that's why
she likes me but she [__] made a
decision prior to you open your damn
mouth yeah sometimes it's like it's like
a thing where they go oh I really said
all the right things it's like bro she
liked you because you were 5 11. yeah so
be five eleven you have all the Rings
the coolest thing I ever did and I had a
100 success rate with it but I only did
it twice was I was at a bar and there's
a chick across the way and I see her her
look at me twice
and then I I was like
and she gets up and you [__] walks
over and sits down next is that sick all
you did was get up and leave
because then you knew she had trauma
you're like whoa
what kind of chair were you sitting in
stool and I think in a stool you look
like you're five eleven enough
that could be what it is it could be
just not the fact that yeah what if it
was a pair of a pair of Sharper Image
massage chairs that makes a little more
sense I'm hey I'm rushing over there
dude okay I got this one primed for you
more incentive you got it you got the
heat it's already hot yeah
second time I did it the chick comes
over right and she sits down next to me
and then she's like Oh I thought you
were getting up and leaving him I have
my friend over there and I was like
yo like come over here
so when that when that lady came over
and sat next to you what was the first
thing that you guys said to each other I
went
in your head where you're like I can't
I can't I can't believe this is working
I can't believe this is working I was
like
so what's your name what do you do what
do you do for a living
your beers
and she's like I want to sit here those
rings that are already easy to spill
like a martini you know what coinbase
doesn't have good liquidity
thank you
do you guys think do you guys believe
that Riz actually like for what it means
actually leads to Quality relationships
with people
I don't even know what the [__] it is
still you read the definition I read the
definition he wasn't listening to you
it's almost like intent I know but like
manipulation intent right is that what
is I don't I don't think it's that
manipulate I honestly just think it's a
new age word for like spitting game yeah
okay I'm calling this to careful let's
try to figure out what is it I believe
confused because like even game is like
most women kind of know they're being
gamed and it doesn't I don't know if
that leads to like the right thing like
if you're just trying to hook up yeah
like be cool but then like
most meaningful relationships kind of
didn't start that way right I think
there's innocent game spitting did you
spit game at Nina when you were like
yeah I definitely acted way different
for example I was just nice the whole
time
um I like it's uh
she was in Irvine at the times and I was
in LA so even just the the choice for me
to drive to Irvine to spend even a small
amount of time I feel like it was
already like whoa you know what I'm
saying like I'm supposed to be busy like
doing my work or whatever and then I'm
still visiting her while she's like in
between like classes or some [__] like
that but the reality is Anthony's just
getting ready and he's waiting four
hours it's like finally let's go
and then there's also like uh not uh
proves not the right word but like not
being like uh you know sexual or [__]
for quite some time like taking things
slow even though I was making the effort
to be present or be around or like even
if things would get close or things
would be like intimate still not making
moves like that and just giving it space
you know what I mean therefore like
because you're not getting physical of
course you have to be like just talking
in a very charismatic way so I feel like
that was like part of the game to like
not give it up quickly because I was
also just trying to figure it out for
myself too you know but she was like a
Target you had in your stuff he's not
easy you were like I needed to get
closer I think when I made the decision
to try yeah that was it like that's
that's the call because it was such an
effort this guy's [__] Top Gun dude
you sound like Michael Jordan right now
in game seven you're like I decided I'm
gonna win this game I had the flu you
know no just kidding that's sick though
yeah but what's the difference between
game and just flirting
you know what I think I think at the end
of the day it's really important to just
be yourself
I feel like uh everybody can flirt but
not everybody has game
oh 100 you gotta find your style though
I think some people yeah they need to
use next line but you need to it needs
to sound like it's you you got to be
self-aware a little bit right you gotta
know where your strengths are I want to
use this hate sounding like this hate
sounding like this guy but he's right
yeah dude but it's alive I think
whatever you got to do to find your
comfort zone when you're speaking to
someone you do have to be comfortable
with yourself sure yeah that's cute okay
you guys don't believe the pickup artist
stuff you just gotta I actually don't
believe you just gotta break them down
so they feel like there are three so
then yeah I don't I don't they'll get
with you I find it hilarious I don't
believe it leads to Quality
relationships I think you might get that
day done but again I think half the game
is is uh to the credit of the girl she
already wanted you and you're just a lot
of dudes miscredit themselves can I say
I think negging is a short-term strategy
you imply that you that you use
for a little bit of time you don't you
don't do it all the time so the guy with
one relationship like yeah that's how I
got him now that's how I got him come on
oh man that me up
nagging leaves to picking because
weirdo dude yeah but you're just gonna
get some [__] negging leads to jeggings
like you're getting pegged jagging is
not good
do you do you negative
just for playfulness sometimes
early on yeah a little bit but like in a
in a very over-the-top like jokey way
you're busting balls right you're
busting balls dude busting balls is like
my love language I [__] love but you
know what that's I think busting balls
is a harder art than just being like a
good person I think that's like way like
you that's a finer line I think most
dudes miss the mark like pretty bad
that's black belt [__] yeah because also
a lot of women are like uh they don't
want to be uncomfortable either and
they'll just kind of laugh it off but
they really don't like it you know what
I mean like some dudes are just really
laying it in wrong and they're just
trying to get through the conversation
straight up crying yeah I see that I see
that a lot where they're just like they
just want to be a pleasant person so
they're just going with it's like oh I
didn't like that you gotta do the
sandwich technique you gotta go
compliment neg compliment and then it's
a nice face not a lot of medium
sandwiches hate your arms great legs
great Jegs yeah
well when you say it like that I it
makes me question my own Theory I think
you go up and you're like hi I like
bigger girls
yeah don't say it don't say it no but
then it's like and it's like oh hold on
a second I was trying to nag you
my intention was to Nay but now I just
sound like an ass to be fair like
nagging is a freaking that is a key
tactic for getting traumatized girls
I hate to say it but if you're damaged
goods that is you flock to that yeah
dude daddy issues is my thing too daddy
issues daddy issues is the baddest hack
that's the baddest it really is my thing
it's I think you should go to jail for
exploiting daddy issues I know are we
feeling awesome at least there's no law
but when they but when they actually get
it that's a handful for them
like when they actually get it's a
handful for them it's like they're only
choosing based on looks Colleen can I
ask you a question can you just help us
out a little bit bro like can you just
give us some insight because I feel like
you have the secrets to the book but
you're not sharing it with them she's
not gonna sell out her entire you kind
of have to bro I mean going back to what
you said so beautifully I think if
you're just authentic
get into the [__] point no I mean to
be honest it really helps if if she's
already attracted to you first I mean
that's just kind of what it is damn so
it's all about looks
it gets your foot in the door yeah for
sure for sure it makes a lot easier but
you get when your foot's on the door you
could still give a woman another uh
phrase that I've heard the ick yeah
absolutely that's what I push your foot
out the door yeah and that's even harder
right because and then deadbolt it and
then deadbolt it yeah has you ever had a
friend what what that what that was your
friend but then he became something more
yeah have you turned a friend zone into
a man man Zone man Zone what is a man
Zone you've never been to the man song
yeah it's a man Zone you've never been
in the man Zone oh my God he's never
been to the man are you actually being
serious
the man zone is the place that men take
you when they're courting you yeah yeah
it does yeah step into the man
it's usually in the back of Discovery
Zone now it's called the RIS zone so
yeah that's happened to you to the band
Zone yeah because in one and you know
friend zone they're the friend they're
not they're not a mate they're not your
partner right but a man's own is ooh
that's a man yeah yeah oh yeah oh I
could I could make my life with this man
yep and then when you get with them
that's the danger zone you know do you
believe that opposite sex uh hetero best
friends can be best friends
to them exactly yep and if they're gay
that's very honest answer I just said
hetero
yeah you called it gay they're gay
that's true too
it's true if you're not attracted to
them and nobody has risk
negative rizz relationship yeah I think
that helps right if the other person
just has no game at all how do you um
how does someone find attracted to you
then like it's like
yeah yeah it's like most guys are
invisible has you ever had
has he ever known anybody because you
know I'll tell you what
I'll tell you what I feel like guys
become attractive to some women like
it's like it's not the same where it's
not it's like guys don't
like they'll do a yoga thing and she
goes I'm marrying her yeah we're like I
don't hear the same love at first sight
I'm marrying him thing from women so how
do you capture that you gotta do stuff
around the house you gotta like um but
you gotta get in the house
[Laughter]
he's already telling us what Tim wants
in the marriage I don't know dude and
it's like you gotta get married first
it's not that's not where my examples
are it's not it's not carrier into the
house you gotta make sure you close all
the cabinets when you're done you got to
go hey your Amazon packages arrived yeah
you gotta pick it up
so how do you get noticed in the first
place by women for them to even find you
attractive it's like you're not just
married to them yeah dude I don't know
like maybe like take care of yourself a
little bit good hygiene you know 5
11.00 yeah
yeah damn it I don't have anything we
got five eleven seated we got a circus
freaked
how important is height I feel like
height is like constantly throwed in
there and um it's a preference it's a
preference so like so that's like a foot
in the door thing because that has
nothing to do with somebody's like
character you're just like I I can see
the diff why come you guys get all hung
up on that one there are unicorns that
really don't care but we already know
that it's the [__] first thing
Hannah's taller than me I I'm dated
shorter guys before so
how'd you feel about it where are they
now dead did you hear the way she talked
about it she threw it away they were in
a ditch she rolled her eyes they got no
Blues they got no ribs
the skulls got no skin on it but how
short though like an inch shorter uh
like could you wear heels okay
very good
[Music]